from bloomberg quick take i'm renita
young and this is
your money story now it's february it's
black history month
and today i want to introduce you to
ross mack
he's the wall street rapper who hosts
maconomics on
on revolt tv and we're going to talk
about creating generational wealth
in the black community ross thank you so
much for joining me today
thank you so much for having me and i
love this conversation
we're getting ready to have absolutely
absolutely so let's jump right into it
you're another kid from chicago you grew
up in the south shore neighborhood
very close to where first lady michelle
obama grew up at and you went to her
high school
tell me how you became aware of
financial literacy was
was it a general conversation growing up
at home
i will say coming from the south side no
one is thinking about financial literacy
um it's something that you don't
understand until you're exposed to
different backgrounds right and i think
what one of the biggest things you think
about kind of the wealth gap in the
community is also a
exposure gap right and the reason i say
that is because
you're never thinking about um you know
investing in the stock market until
you're exposed to that my first time
truly getting exposed to it
was when i was 18 years old at upenn
right in a warden class and a kid
sitting next to me was day trading in
the middle of econ class
and so when you're starting to think
about the different levels of exposure
um that's what i find to be so important
to try to get people more exposed to it
but coming from the south side
you know you're truly not thinking about
it the most you're thinking about is
saving
i think um you know grandparents and
parents might instill
in some of some of the children to this
day is you need to save money
um but no one truly understands you know
that saving is still
technically losing money due to the the
rise in inflation every year so
um you know no one is truly thinking
about that you're absolutely right and
let's jump into this experience you've
had that brought you to
revolt eventually to host maconomics but
you studied at some of the world
renowned institutions and worked at some
of them
tell us the journey there how you
started to learn
no that's an awesome question so my
journey that helped me
say i needed to find um you know my true
passion with helping other people
get to financial literacy was purely me
being submerged in a culture that i felt
as though at first was actually a
culture shock
and that being going to upend uh a
school that at the time i want to say
was maybe seven percent
african-american and one of the things
that i took away was that there are
different levels to wealth in this
country
and i think you know going into it
coming from the south side of chicago
my idea of what rich was
was obviously not the exact same thing
and so
as i continued to continue to be
submerged in the culture
you know i ended up you know being very
lucky being a part of
morgan stanley's richard b fisher
program that allowed me to intern
my freshman summer and so every summer
of
college while some of my best friends
would be at home you know back in
chicago i would only be able to come
home for call it a week or two before i
would be off
to living in new york and interning and
it was there where
you know you start to understand
different ways of life and different uh
ways of thinking when it comes to
actually building and accumulating
wealth
and so for me you know one of the
biggest needs was saying you know what
how can i find a better way
coming from the south side of chicago
now being a person that i consider to be
lucky
to actually be exposed to different
levels of wealth and more importantly
different
levels of thinking especially when it
comes to the actual wealth
accumulation conversation and so for me
it was how can i instantly bring my own
life experiences
back to the community that i come from
because if i know
if i knew what i know now life would be
completely different and i would say the
same for
the majority of inner cities right i
think if parents understood you know
different ways of investing different
forms of life insurance or things of
that sort i think you know
the conversations would be a lot better
people better understood budgeting
you know i think uh the overall
financial
um you know the overall financial health
in certain communities would be a lot
better
absolutely when you lift up communities
that have been disproportionately set
back for years hundreds of years that
helps
um that helps make our country more
competitive on the international stage
you know when you lift up
different communities and so let's keep
on that
on that route of the wealth gap it's
been widening over the past 30
years the st louis fed sent out a report
not too long ago that showed this
and so the pandemic exacerbated it
and you have a growing black wealth
matters community
on social media platforms i got a chance
to listen into one of your clubhouse
rooms this past wednesday but first let
us know
your personal reason as to why black
wealth
matters yeah um for me i think
that we had a very trying 2020
not just from a global pandemic
standpoint but from a
emotional standpoint especially after
george floyd's
um murder right and so for me one of the
things that i wanted to do was find a
better
uh way of truly walking and living in my
purpose and that purpose is
bringing wall street to main street and
so when you start to think about
you know the wealth gap like i say it's
always the information gap and so
for me it is how do we better inform how
do we better educate
our community because like you say 2020
was a trying year
but the wealth gap only got larger and
larger where you had the majority of
people being unemployed being
black people um better yet people of
color african-americans
and mexicans or hispanics um i think one
of the things you want to ask yourself
is
how what how's that gap able to continue
to get wider and wider while
you know the the fed was effectively
pumping up the stock market right
in order to try to spur the economy ever
since obama got in
office they've you know strategically
kept interes interest rates low
which effectively means the stock market
is going to continue to grow
but you ask yourself that um
african americans own one percent of the
stock market so for me
it is something that i've been trying to
champion and try to get our people not
only to budget better
not only to start thinking about real
estate and other forms of assets to
actually pass down for generational
wealth
but we have to invest in the stock
market right one of the conversations i
was trying to help inform people
was you can't fight the fed what's been
going on with the fed
is they are effectively inflating in
order to pump
up america's economy and what that means
is that the stock market is going to
continue to grow
so when you think about this past year
um the wealth gap
got much larger because the government
pumped trillions of dollars into the
economy
whereas some people got it in the form
of stimulus checks
while the vast majority got it in the
form of
seeing their 401ks seeing their
retirement accounts
um growing massively as well as seeing
their brokerage accounts growing
massively so for me
it is always a big thing to continue to
tell people listen
we have to start investing we have to
understand that you know you're never
gonna
out earn someone right you have to have
your money working for you and so for me
you know black wealth matters is
something that is a fully
uh encompassing way of life of thinking
where it starts with budgeting better
where it starts with paying down debt
and then it's all about thinking about
you know having that emergency fund for
rainy day a lot of people saw that
you know with the lack of job security
especially in this entire
country right but we saw the people of
color actually get laid off first
especially women as well they get
um you know there's a stat that said you
know there are more women that are being
laid off than men as well so
for me it's always like fully
encompassing how do we truly build
wealth
and one of the avenues is we have to
invest in the stock market
i find it that a statistic that by 2053
the actual um net worth of african
america is going to be zero
right zero so for me my purpose
is how can i hopefully push that off and
better yet
never have that stat even come into
fruition
right and so for me it is all about
finding ways to ensure
that we are educated on everything right
when you look at what today is
we're we're we're in the most
technological
savvy generation ever right everyone is
able to learn
information is disseminated on all
platforms whether it's
facebook instagram youtube what have you
right obviously you guys are doing a
phenomenal job at quick take
but what i say this to say is that we no
longer have um
we no longer have an excuse right
obviously if you come from a
um underserved community chances are
your neighborhood schools were
underfunded right we no longer could
have the excuse that
um you know our schools aren't teaching
us this because technically speaking
most schools aren't teaching financial
literacy which that's a conversation for
another day i think
it needs to be implemented i want to
talk to um the cps president here in
chicago i want to start
implementing something in the schools
but what's happening is that you know
other community groups are having
conversations at the dinner room table
right um community groups are being
uh being able to benefit from their
grandparents passing away and leaving a
life insurance policy
other groups are being able to benefit
from the fact that their grandparents
and their parents have
property that they're also able to
inherit right
in areas that once were not redlined so
therefore those property values are also
increasing so for me black wealth
matters is a movement
which is which is truly predicated on a
fully encompassing plan
of helping people become more educated
about the different avenues to grow
their wealth
brilliantly said brilliantly said and
before we get into more of your very
practical ways
that the black community can start this
uh i was listening in on the clubhouse
this past wednesday you do black wealth
wednesdays
you take questions from people you give
investment advice so do your moderators
and you and another moderator were
talking about building generational
wealth for black people for the next
200 years before we get into how
can you just explain to us what that
kind of a mindset
does for one's confidence and how it can
change the trajectory
of their lives absolutely there's a
actual you know scientific um
you know scientific understanding of
that you know
having money problems is correlated
negatively correlated with your
happiness right and so
the moment people become financially
free their lives
their their i believe their lifespan
will be longer and i believe they will
live a
more fulfilling life right and so when
it comes to actually
building generational wealth it is the
ability to pass on assets to the next
generation
right and i think the way you start
thinking about that
is thinking not short-term but long-term
right and i think that the when you
start thinking about the
the buying power of the black community
right
wrapped around two trillion dollars and
you start asking yourself
you know if we were spending that money
in the right places you know
what would that do for the next
generations to come and that's kind of
where
where i try to stand in right try to
fill in that gap that information gap
where should you be spending that money
and i might actually take that a step
back not necessarily even spending that
money what should you be investing that
money
and that's how we're thinking about you
know building that generational wealth
and i think
you know people aren't educated on you
know certain
um you know certain of these
conversations right i think at the end
of the day
you know i went to some of the best
schools that i would say right um
but i i still don't necessarily need to
know what an isosceles triangle is
but i definitely want to know i want i
shouldn't
have learned how to buy a home the
importance of actually having a
retirement right when you start thinking
about
people constantly working in public
service or something like that
until they're past their 70s it's
something that is a problem in our
entire country
for me it's always about finding ways to
help people start thinking about
generational wealth
and you start with like i say one of the
basic forms
is just having life insurance you'll be
surprised the earlier you start how
cheap it could be
to actually cover you and your family
when you look
it'll probably be the same price as
having
you know spotify apple music and netflix
right you start thinking about it it
could be literally maybe three drinks at
a nightclub
right and everyone's already spending
money on
you know things that is not actually
bringing them any true value
um full term right and that's what it's
always about helping people put things
into perspective
to actually think about building
generational wealth for their children
and their children's children
absolutely and if you've just tuned in
you are watching your money story on
quick take i'm renita young and this is
ross mack the wall street rapper wharton
alum
morgan stanley alum who now hosts
maconomics
on revolt tv we're talking about
creating generational wealth in the
black community
ross give us your three practical tips
on how the black community can begin
building generational wealth
phenomenally phenomenally uh said
right how can you know black community
start building generational wealth i
think
once again it's a fully encompassing way
of life of thinking
but i think you know practically
thinking i think everyone should start
better budgeting
i think budgeting gives you a better
outlook on helping you reach your goals
and making sure that you are
not um left holding the bag anytime a
unforeseen um you know expenses
coming some some expense comes to to
your life right at the end of the day i
want to say about
70 of people don't have a thousand
dollars saved in their bank account and
that's americans that's not a black
white or hispanic
problem that is an american problem
right so for me it's like
i think people need to start off
budgeting better um because
a lot of people live out of their means
you know when i say budgeting
i have a free downloadable worksheet
that you can literally use
um download to computer you can use it
because it will help you start tracking
the your necessary expenses which i
believe from your take-home pay you
shouldn't be
spending more than 50 on and that is
call it housing
you know food food shelter obviously
whether it's mortgage or
rent um as well as different you know
forms of insurance or things of that
sort
and then next with the remaining 50 um
you should
have roughly like 30 going towards the
things that you want to do
whether that's you know entertainment or
um you know dining out or
anything traveling or anything like that
and then the 20 should be
built towards saving paying down debt as
well as investing
right and so i think that for every
person is going to be situationally
but you need to kind of pivot and shift
you know towards different you know
percentages but you know especially in a
time if you don't if you're not in a
position of having true job security it
might be 50 50
you might not even need once right you
might truly be saying let me build up my
emergency fund
which is three to six months of your
necessary expenses and that way
you're gonna be better off right you're
not living paycheck to paycheck because
you now have a six-month cushion
especially if you have children you want
to start having that cushion
um and then next i think we need to
start thinking about investing
it is something that you know it's the
only way i believe to truly
start helping people uh allow their
money to make money i think in this
society we're taught to work hard for
money
but we're never truly taught um that our
money could work even harder for us
and you know in in would and i
understand um i think that
you know when it's all said and done one
thing that a lot of people aren't
you know and it could be you know
rightfully so but a lot of
you know people of color are less
inclined to want to invest their money
in the stock market because
they're they can't see their money they
don't know what's going on we heard one
bad story
but the reality is the stock market um
and i'm a
you know say the s p 500 is indicative
of that it's growing 10
annually on average right and so to give
you an idea
you know you can make a million dollars
purely putting 250
in every month into the s p 500. i tell
people that
but one thing that they don't understand
is well i want to get rich quickly
right so i i i
you don't a lot of people don't have the
foresight and the the ability to be
you know kind of long-sighted to
actually say okay i want to be very
disciplined
and make money in the long term right
and so people need to invest
whether it's in your brokerage account
whether it's in your
um you know your child's custodial
account or your 401k or roth
ira and i think maybe the last one you
know so we said budgeting and investing
um you you don't mind if i said do
two more right because i think um
family i think every family who has
someone that depends on them
needs life insurance um because it is i
believe one of the easiest ways
um that allows you to um
truly build generational wealth and pass
it on to the next generation right no
one wants to think about their untimely
demise
but that's the only thing that's sure in
this world right we all are going to
pass on at some point
wouldn't it be amazing to pass on and
not have your family have to
do a gofundme for your funeral expenses
wouldn't it be nice to
um you know because when you think about
it it's going to cause emotional stress
on your family when you pass away
but it should not also cause financial
stress on your family when you pass away
and so
having life insurance whether it's you
know a 40
a month plan or 60 a month plan at the
end of the day
everyone makes finds time to do what
they want to do and everybody can
effectively budget for certain expenses
in their life and you know ensure
life insurance is one of them and i
think the fourth one that i want to say
is truly investing for your children um
you know one terrible status i want to
say the average
um american has like 50 000 in debt and
i want to say the average college
student is graduating with about 30 000
in student loans one of the greatest
gifts to give your child
is the ability not to incur student
loans and
you know one way to think about that is
a 529 account
it's effectively called it like a roth
ira it allows you to put
after tax money into a into an account
that being a 529 account
that money is now invested into the
stock market it's gonna be in mutual
funds and that money is going to grow
tax-free you're going to be able to take
that money out tax-free
you're going to be able to utilize that
money for um your child so literally
putting a hundred dollars in a month
you're going to have calling maybe over
70k
in 18 years for your child maybe even
more right depending on you know what
your investments are
and i think that's something that people
need to establish for the children and
lastly
in that same realm of helping uh plan
for your child's future
a custodial account i think a custodial
account is very important
um it is just a a brokerage account for
your child
right it gives them the ability to one
start learning about money start
learning about
the things that are important and one of
them is truly investing and that's how
you build for the future
that's how you build generational wealth
absolutely and
you said also that you and your wife are
doing the same for your four-month-old
daughter
uh she has a custodial account so this
is this is how you build
generational wealth um and if you are
just tuning in
this is your money story on quick take
this is ross mack we're talking to the
wall street rapper
and the host of revolt tv's mackonomics
who
wants to what ross i want to help you
get to the back
that's right now we do have a quick
question from the audience
uh one person asks should i start
investing in stocks now during the
pandemic what do you say ross
i think that's a great question and you
know one thing that i always say you
know give a disclaimer definitely
check with maybe a registered advisor or
something but
i think the questions you want to ask
yourself before you start investing
because the short answer is yes
but you know the long-winded answer is
it depends and so assuming that
you have an emergency fund set up
assuming that you don't have any debt
the answer is absolutely and the reason
i say that is because when you start
investing you need to think about
being a long-term investor the stat that
i told you was that
over the long course of time the stock
market the s p 500 is going to get you
a 10 return understand why that's
important is because
your money is more than likely in your
savings checkings account
that is maybe getting you 0.06 return
so understand that you want to find a
way to actually start allowing your
money to make money for you
but even more important is by only
having your money
in a savings checking account you're not
even
outpacing inflation right the the when
you think about
inflation that's something that you
might not necessarily know the actual
concept but you definitely
understand it because when you could go
to your corner store as a kid
with a dollar you could probably live
leave out with a handful of goods right
you had quarter bags of chips
gum was a quarter 50 cent um juices or
you know 50 cent
honey buns or whatnot reality is now you
take that same dollar to your corner
store you're getting a 79 cent bag
maybe a 10 15 cent bag to put it in
right like that's
you know that's the power of inflation
right your your rent is higher gas is
higher than it was when your
your parents were younger that's
inflation the cost of living goes up
every year
two to three percent annually so
therefore you want to find a way
to at least keep pace or outpace
inflation and so you know just coming
back full circle
you know to the question of should you
start investing and the reason i say you
don't want to have
debt let's talk about the the different
types of debt right
the other day like i say the average
return is 10 percent so
it does not make sense if you have
credit card debt that you're paying 18
to 22 percent on
reason being it doesn't make sense
because
if you're investing in the stock market
to get 10 percent but yet you're still
paying 22
on your credit cards that's the type of
debt i don't want you to have
you can have mortgage you can have you
know um
you can have mortgage you have certain
student loans or something like that
but you know the idea is you know you
want to get rid of bad debt before you
start investing because you don't want
to be
stuck with um paying 20 while you're
only effectively making 10 percent
mm-hmm well put again and so on that
note
you you say long-term investing is the
way to go but we saw a whole lot of
short-term investors
get into the game last week with
gamestop mania
first can you please give us your
assessment
of what happened there
amazing question what happened with the
gamestop mania
um in short you know to kind of educate
people watching right now
it was a very well orchestrated um
very well orchestrated uh trading that
in that incurred so
to take it back a few seconds what is
shorting um you had some companies
some hedge funds i'm sorry some the
biggest name would have been melvin
capital
what you had was them saying i want to
bet against gamestop
i believe the stock of gamestop is going
to continue to go down so the way they
would actually do that
they would call their broker effectively
like their bank
they would call their uh their broker
and they would say hey i want to short
gamestop
their broker would say sure okay and
we'll just continue to say melbourne
capital so melbourne capital will say by
the way i'm going to show it well
it's the in order to short they would
have to borrow the shares
they would then immediately sell it to
someone else with the expectation that
the price goes down
and the way they kind of make good on
that is they go out and then they buy
game stock shares that are cheaper they
then deliver those shares back and they
kind of take the difference right so if
gamestop is trading at twenty dollars
they will borrow it sell it to you know
person b
um the stock goes down to ten dollars
they go buy the stock back at ten
dollars and they make that kind of ten
dollar difference because
they borrow that twenty and they give it
back at ten dollars right that's
effectively how that works
and so what ended up happening was that
gamestop had um call it almost like a
concert that has only 100 seats
you had people selling 140 seats for a
concert that only had
um 100 seats so in other words they had
140 percent of their actual
they only had call it they only had 100
shares well they had people betting
against 140 of those so in other words
they had 140
short so the reason i say it was well
orchestrated because you had a very
powerful reddit channel
called wall street vets who got privy to
that and they said guys if we all buy
gamestop right now that's going to force
you know these hedge funds and once
again we can consider this being melvin
capital
that's going to force them to actually
have to go out
and buy it back because their broker is
going to call
call melvin capital like hey buddy um
you borrowed this at 20. now it's forty
dollars i need you to kind of pay it
back right they're gonna
they're gonna it's gonna that's what you
call a margin call right they're
gonna require them to give me the shares
back that you borrowed
or put up more capital right for
collateral and
instead what ended up happening is
companies that were short like melvin
capital
um maybe cintron as well they were
forced to go out to the public market
and buy back the stock and what ended up
happening you know gamestop obviously
is a poor cup is a company that was
obviously on a deterioration right
it was going down but what ended up
happening there was a technical in the
market that made
um people have to buy the stock right
and or like i say in order for melbourne
capital make good
with you know their bank they had to buy
the stock so the stock went from 40
to 80 200 300 400
and the reason is because melbourne
capital had to buy it you had people
that were forced buyers because um and
that's what you call a short squeeze
right the people that were short
their banks called them and they said
hey you have to uh buy these stocks back
you have to deliver these stocks back
right and that's what you call a short
squeeze
and what made this um what made this
story even
more complex or even uh convoluted was
the fact that
melvin capital ended up almost going out
of business because they lost so much
money on this trade
so they ended up getting bailed out by
one particular hedge fund
in in in particular and that is being
citadel
now this is when the story gets a little
more interesting because
citadel um what was synonymous with the
reddit traders the wall street bets is
everyone technically were using the
robin hood platform
right and so it's when it comes to like
a little triangle
like a love triangle right so what ended
up happening you had melvin capital
being outsmarted technically
um that you know technically by the
reddit traders who were all using robin
hood
then you had citadel who bailed out
melvin capital
um but here's the thing citadel is also
one of the largest clients of robin hood
so citadel bailed out melbourne capital
melbourne capital we're losing at the
expense of
the reddit traders that were using robin
hood but
robin hood technically gets their money
from citadel when you think about it so
what ended up happening what made this
very um you know very complex
or made it uh made his way to the news
so to speak you had aoc and ted cruz
talking about it was that robin hood
effectively tied the hands of the
investors and they said hey
um everyone on the robin hood you no
longer can buy this stock
you can only sell so everyone
understands supplied
supply demand dynamics um and what ended
up happening was
everyone technically were s in order if
only if people were only allowed to sell
that means the stock had to go down
so it went from 400 to quickly 300 200
and that's because no one could ever buy
the stock anymore if no one can buy it
you can't support the market therefore
the price has to go down
and so as the price was going down you
had ted cruz alc and other people
coming out speaking um whether it was
elon or any and
you know other people coming out
speaking they were literally saying this
is unfair
you know the market is rigged and what
ended up happening is that a lot of
people unfortunately that got into the
robin hood mania
who didn't truly understand the risk
associated with it lost
a lot of money because they were buying
it oh it's going to 200 it's going to
300
and they're buying it there and you know
robin hood made it so that you no longer
could buy the stock therefore the stock
uh price actually went down that's true
and so
as a result robin hood is facing at
least
30 lawsuits um for stopping people from
buying stocks
now what's your thought about that you
know is this hampering
um the main street guy the little guy
the everyday person
is it really fair to the everyday person
who's really trying to come up
yeah um i think when you think about you
know what
robin hood actually did you know and you
asked the question uh
you know surrounding the legality as
well as the fairness
it's a very you know that's that's one
of those my
my opinion really isn't going to matter
you know my opinion was they should have
allowed
um everyone to continue to trade but
what ended up happening was that
um effectively robin hood also could
have went out of
business because you know they're
clearing houses required them to put up
more capital
because there was so much volume going
on so much volatility in the stock
you know at the end of the day when we
buy a stock we don't understand but we
technically don't
get that stock until two days right and
so what ended up happening
is that robin hood or whoever's our
broker they are technically holding that
stock for us
and so it doesn't clear into two days
and so the clearinghouses effectively
told robin hood hey you need to
um you need to be more capitalized right
and i think that
what's going to come out of this is like
i say i don't believe robin hood should
have did this they should have found a
way
to make it work some way somehow because
what ended up happening is
everyone had was left with a bad taste
in their mouth and when you have
uh gamestop and amc and nokia blackberry
or whatnot
those prices going up 200 coming down 70
80 percent the next day
that's problematic especially when
you're ta they're tying the hands of
your investors
your people that are using robert's hand
you can't buy it then the next day okay
you can buy it but you can only buy one
share
and that's very problematic because now
you have the big guys that are just
selling selling selling
and they're making money as the stock
goes down and so that's going to be
problematic they're definitely going to
have to go before the senate
and they're going to have to pay some
probably hefty fines but what
what's going to come out of this is that
you know brokerage firms are going to
have to be
better capitalized moving forward um
i think there was something that was
very uh unfortunate and definitely
left um a lot of people holding the bag
um but
that goes to show you know that's what
um learning how to invest the right way
um what would have could have actually
helped you know people avoid this
because you know you want to buy great
companies
that are going to be here for the next
five ten years and you hold those guys
for
you know for life and that's kind of the
biggest life lesson right
i just saw um on the news earlier or on
social media
but a young man you know took his life
because he lost about 185 000
in this whole gamestop phenomenon and
it's it's something that you know
the the class excuse me the class action
lawsuits are going to continue to get
bigger
so i think that what's all said and done
that you know what what could have
avoided that
is robin hood being better capitalized
robin hood still allowing people to buy
and sell that way they just kind of
remove themselves from that equation and
let the actual market itself play out
but because they made it so that they
couldn't buy
is they kind of made it look like they
were tampering with with the market
um okay you know what on that note about
the reddit traders
do you know anything about the
demographics of who was trading
um within the reddit group do you have
any buddies who were
also um included um yeah i definitely
have buddies that were in it without a
doubt i have
a investment club um where people were
telling me hey should i buy should i buy
and i was telling them
i would recommend staying away from it
and one of the things that i help my
uh the people that are in my economics
investment club is look
i share my screen let's go through the
10k right now right that is the
annual filing that you know gamestop has
to file every year
right and i said let's look at this
business let's look at their top line
sales
let's look at their revenue do we
believe that gamestop should be up this
high
purely based on maybe the the the sales
of the xbox and playstation
five consoles probably not right um
and so what we ended up doing was we
truly valued the company and said this
company is not a
at one point it was a 30 billion dollar
valuation company and i told them
absolutely not
i don't recommend you guys buying it and
so what ended up happening
is the people that were in this reddit
channel were people that were
effectively buying it you know purely
based on what someone else said oh let's
all buy it
all right let's hold the line you have
people coming out with it
on you have people coming out on social
media and saying yo let's let's
let's continue to hold it till it gets
to a thousand and you know at the end of
the day i do believe there were wolves
in sheep clothing
who kind of were on both sides hedge
funds that were also on the reddit
channel
maybe helping pump it up because when
it's all said and done you had a lot of
unsophisticated people
getting into the stock not knowing that
it was probably
a big bubble when it was going to burst
and it happened very quickly
okay excellent assessment of what
happened there um
all right we have another question from
the audience someone wants to know
how can a non-american venture into
investing in the s p
500 great question um
i think you know a non-american can't
own
stocks i'm sorry can't own american
american-based stocks i'm not certain on
which you know what country you're at or
but at the end of the day you know just
how i can own um
chinese listed companies um or african
listed companies you know whether it's
nioh or junior
you yourself in whatever country you are
are able to own
american um own companies um i i think
you just want to check with your
um local brokerage firms and try to
figure out but you know to that person
you know you can own um s p 500 via
you know two very common etfs a vanguard
one
that the ticker is v o o and another one
is s p
y but you would literally ask your
broker how can you own
vo or spy and that's gonna give you the
ability to own
um in one basket of goods 500 of
america's best
performing and larger companies okay
okay and one more question from the
audience where do you see the biggest
opportunities right now to invest
great great question biggest
opportunities to invest are
you know for me it's always thinking
about long term um five to ten years
down the line and so one of the things
you want to think about
is where's the world going to look like
i believe the entire world
everyone's going green you're seeing by
2035 the vast majority of the world
is trying to go green meaning they're no
longer
making selling combustible engines aka
gas powered cars so the world is going
to be electric
you want to have you want to own
electric cars you want to own
the entire infrastructure of electric
cars so the charging stations
the battery manufacturers and the actual
um you know natural resource that makes
the batteries that being lithium
lithium-ion so you want to look at that
entire landscape you're going to want to
also
look into semiconductors you're going to
also look at
you know kind of cloud data companies um
you know the list goes on i think that
you know if you have any further
questions
you could for sure shoot me a text um
that's always one great way
to get it to uh finally learn more about
it
of the best sectors 773-232-2577 be in
for the next five ten years
okay thanks for running that down too i
mean people you're getting all kinds of
uh investment advice from ross mack the
wall street rapper
revolt tv host of maconomics who wants
to help you
get to that back okay and last up
let's round out the conversation we
started out talking about creating
generational wealth in the black
community
and so this is not just a responsibility
of the people within the community um
ross you and i talked about this tell me
how
allies can help create generational
wealth
in the black community yeah um great
great question how can allies help
build generational wealth i think that
it boils down to
representation on all levels it boils
down to
you know giving more job opportunities
to qualified you know people of color i
think that
when it's all said and done we need
representation and
you know kind of the c-suite areas of
some of these large corporations
we need better um we need better
you know philanthropic efforts when it
comes to
helping educate um some communities um i
think that you know
simply writing a blank check you know
just for tax write-off is no longer
going to cut it i think that you
probably should try to find better ways
to partner with certain
organizations you know my my
organization is all about
trying to help educate the youth um you
know i talk to
several kids every every month for that
same reason and i think
when it comes to the allies it's you
know how do you help um
create a world that is more fair whether
it's from job opportunities whether it's
from
you know the ability to generate income
whether it's from banks um
loaning uh equally to certain
communities
um whether it's from certain companies
no longer doing predatory lending
and you know thousand percent interest
rate loans to you know people in certain
communities i think it's a fully
uh encompassing um you know thing that
needs to occur but one thing for sure is
you know equal access to education
excuse me equal access to uh job
opportunities and just
trying to have you know the world uh
represent you know
you know what what this country should
be and that's you know equality for all
and so
i think that's one way alaska truly
helped you know this
quest for helping the black community
build true generational wealth
it sounds like what you're saying ross
is use whatever influence you have to
help create a way
for people of color for black people who
go
to generational wealth yeah absolutely
you said
you said everything i was trying to say
in five seconds
oh thank you so much but hey listen i
enjoyed this conversation
thank you so much for coming on this is
ross
mack everybody host of mackonomics on
revolt tv
i'm ranita young you just watched your
money story on bloomberg quick take
thank you so much and have a great day
everybody
thank you so much